So far, whenever we make a search, we'll
retrieve all the objects of that type.
For example, when we search for
notebooks we'll want all of them.
However, if we want to display
the notes within a notebook,
we must filter out all the notes
that belong to other notebooks.
How can we do this filter trick?
With one of the crown jewels of cocoa,
NSPredicate.
NSPredicate is a class from back in
the old Objective-C days when blocks,
which are Objective-C's version
of closures, were not available.
NSPredicate's still have their place,
notably in core data.
Predicates allows us to define filters
to select specific elements of an array
using a very simple language
called predicate language.
Let's see an example.